Ian Bremmer is the founder and president
of the Eurasia group a political risk
consultancy good morning in let's start
the news from the president's comments
this morning at the g20 summit he warned
about severe actions against North Korea
but then he then he quickly added that
doesn't mean we're going to do them
doesn't that just encapsulate that there
really are no good options when it comes
to North Korea well I mean it's why
we've had a series of presidents that
have basically kicked it to their
children right we we can put more
pressure on China and even though
everyone's gonna focus on the Trump
Putin meeting the most important thing
at the g20 is the fact the us-china
relationship is considerably more tense
this will be the first time that most
presidents have met face to face since
they've in a series of actions already
taken by the United States against China
including a big new arms sale to Taiwan
and also most recently Trump saying
repeatedly the China's not doing what
they need to on North Korea what's the
specific ask from China the specific ask
is that if you don't cut off
significantly the economic funding and
support that the north the Koreans have
been receiving from China that the u.s.
is going to put sanctions against
Chinese organizations doing that
business and eventually there's gonna be
linkage as well to broader tariffs
against China two most important
economies in the world thought that
relationship was on a relatively calm
footing now it looks like it really
isn't that's that's the biggest takeaway
the g20 yeah certainly after the
mar-a-lago meeting where as they
everything seemed to be you know on good
terms what happened he and can you get
that back on track look I mean remember
the first time that Trump met with Obama
in the Oval Office suddenly it was oh
well actually he faced the face
everything's okay he's calling me on the
phone he's spending time but then he's
tapping my phone's right so I think that
Trump was in deal-making mode in let's
see if we can get something done in
relatively short order
he's pivoted away from that very
dramatically and I think this is not
gonna be an easy meeting at all between
Trump and Xi Jinping
that's the body language you want to
watch again the Trump Putin body
language is gonna be warm and festive
and we're all gonna go crazy about it
but with Xi Jinping that's the one that
really has long-term implications that
said the the the Trump Outen meeting is
I mean this has gone from a casual
pull-aside to now this formal byline
discussion essentially a summit between
these two leaders who's going to be
involved in that who should be involved
in that well I mean if that's the case
then Trump's having an awful lot of
summits at this meeting so I wouldn't go
so crazy about it but I do think look we
want to have a lot of people in that
meeting it's important that it's not
just a private bilat between Trump and
Putin because then who the hell knows
what they're talking about I think one
of the reasons that my old friend Fiona
Hill the Senior Director for US Eurasia
is being pulled into that meeting is
because he was gonna be there it looks
that way certainly a lot of people are
pushing for it I think that McMaster
would want her there
she's very credible and the foreign
policy establishment that Richard Haass
types the rest will say you know what if
she's saying that this meeting was on
the up-and-up it's on the up-and-up that
would inoculate Trump from a lot of the
criticism he's otherwise getting critic
no questions no question in The Times
this morning they're saying that Trump
aids are concerned about the meeting
because they're worried about what
President Trump will say or do what's
your definition of success for that
meeting for President Trump well for
Trump and Trump's base it's to ignore
the media ignore the investigation
ignore the rampion and temed lling
absolutely because Obama what I think
Trump was completely right in saying in
Poland today that Obama was president
when the hacks occurred he could have
taken action he didn't and the Trump
said hey if Trump had looked like he was
gonna win Obama probably would have done
more I think that's actually an accurate
analysis but if he had taken action at
the time don't you think President Trump
would have said see they're meddling
with the election of course but Trump
wasn't President Obama is in other words
I kind of expect more from the president
Trump's getting a lot of criticism now
Obama didn't get as much then and we're
kind of forgetting all of that so I do
think that it would be shocking to me if
Trump were actually to bring up the
hacks during this meeting so you don't
think it's wise for him to bring it up
not politically because of course you
know as an as a political animal
anything that potentially legitimizes
his win like the admission of the
Russian hacks hurts him now if he was
gonna put the country before himself
politically then you'd want him to do
that but how many people think that our
presidents put themselves before the
country you say this 20 summit is
different than any other you've ever
seen it is wise because first of all
it's
not a g20 it's a g0 it's an absence of
leadership and and second and the first
time that's really happened but secondly
everyone's gonna be talking about the
elephant in the room they they don't the
vast majority of these presidents do not
like or trust the American president
America first will tell you that and
when he's not directly in front of them
you know what they're gonna be talking
about the entire time is that so clearly
there's gonna be an enormous amount of
news that comes from that all the side
conversations the leaks and how all of
these countries are going to deal with
their increasing questions about the
level of commitment they should have to
the only superpower in the world well
tomorrow we'll know we can always say
president Trump is not predictable you
can say that he's not predictable thank
you very much